- Everything that happened yesterday,
that means nothing.
(applause)
(slow music)
When you're 19,
and you can spend seven full
years learning your craft,
meeting people that are
mentors, being patient,
and you wake up and you're 26 years old,
you have your entire life in front of you
and you've done great foundational work
to go on and then be successful.
I just don't get it,
I don't get why people
think at 18, 22, 30,
that they have to have
their life figured out
when they live to 90 and 100.
- If you could give any
quick piece of advice.
- [Gary] It's patience.
- I'm like lost in life.
You can't be lost in life
when you're this young.
Should you actually have
everything figured out
18 or 20 percent into your life?
Absolutely not,
more importantly than that,
your life evolves and
changes as you get older.
Too many kids don't
take advantage of time.
They're in such a rush to find it,
or be doing it,
that they don't take advantage
of the thing they have.
Figuring everything out is a forever game.
Have you figured out how awesome
you're gonna be as a grandma
when you're still not a grandma?
Whether it's your parents
or yourself, or people,
everybody's trying to
prove something so early.
It's the pressures of society,
the pressures of your siblings,
and most of all the
pressures of your parents.
So many of you are scared to fail,
because your dads gonna
make you feel bad about it.
And I have empathy for that, that sucks.
I'm very fascinated by negative energy
that is not cut-outable.
You need to put your fuckin' earpods in
and listen to positive 24/7
and it'll get you through that.
Or this ideological thing that the media
or culture has put in your head
of what you're supposed to be,
or how you're supposed to roll,
or what's supposed to be happening
at this point is ludicrous.
You're not lost in life,
you're just early in the process.
(upbeat music)
You just don't meet 90 year olds
that talk about how pumped they are
that they made an extra
hundred thousand dollars.
They don't exist.
They talk about regret.
I wish I did,
literally, inevitably, I do this.
I wish is the opening line.
The judgment you put on yourself
that is actually being
fabricated by outside forces
is to me the thing
that I'm trying to
fundamentally break down.
Just fundamentally
trying to break it down.
Everybody's judging
themselves way too early.
You can literally do nothing
for the next eight years,
and be a child.
Time is your asset.
The one thing a 20 year old has over me
is 20 fuckin' years.
But you don't think that,
because when you're 22 you
don't think 31 is young.
- Maybe there's a problem with youth.
- Yeah, I mean that's,
everybody's got strengths and weaknesses.
What a 60 year old has is experience,
but doesn't have time.
What youth has is time.
You can literally do four different things
over the next two years,
six months at a time,
to figure out everything that
you think you might like,
you should try to do.
But that's not what people tell you to do.
- Yeah, they tell you to do your job.
- 100 percent.
What I would do is gather as
many experiences as possible.
Go and travel and learn.
Go and start that business
that you've always wanted.
Hook up with those three teammates
and start that band you've always wanted.
This is the time to be massively risk,
massively risk oriented.
Pick something and fuckin' do it.
You're a fuckin' young kid,
you can do all 19 things.
If you're under 32, 33,
and you're devastated
that you don't have your life figured out,
you're just looking at
the game completely wrong.
Take a breath, take a fuckin' breath.
And so that's what I'm
trying to tell people.
It's what you don't do
that screws with you later on.
The reason you're not winning
and doing what you want
is somebody's opinion,
somebody's opinion of you
matters more to you than
your opinion of yourself.
It's very true.
(applause)